you gotta have a special kind of a
female fan that's like you know
listen man
i know i've been to your show like i've
been to a couple of your your your shows
and smaller venues you got some pretty
wild ass fans that are like
i'm assuming down for a lot of [ __ ] with
you you know what i'm saying oh yeah you
know what i'm i have a motto i
can't do anything with fans so you do
you don't [ __ ] fans i can't that's a
good rule things get weird right um
a lot of things things get weird
um i feel like you also when you do that
you like
okay when someone's a fan of you they're
a fan of everything
the mystery behind you this is this i
feel like when you do that
it goes away they're not they're not a
fan anymore yeah i've already [ __ ]
them yeah i can't that actually makes
sense i don't like it i like girls who
like literally don't know
who i am or don't really know you got me
like
some weird [ __ ]
like you don't know the [ __ ] i am oh
you're gonna find out when you follow me
the russian prostitute yeah it's cool
it's business nice and then after we
just watch tv and eat